Haití preocupa a la comunidad
internacional la violencia por las
pandillas y la inestabilidad política en
el país caribeño causa una crisis
humanitaria sin precedentes desde el
consejo de seguridad de la ONU Nueva
York el ministro de relaciones
exteriores de Haití pidió el despliegue
de una fuerza multinacional en su país
señor presidente la ONU a través de su
consejo de seguridad tiene la
responsabilidad moral de evitar el
naufragio de Haití
el gobierno reitera su renovado pedido
de una sólida asistencia internacional
Para apoyar a los esfuerzos de la
Policía Nacional de Haití en su lucha
contra las bandas armadas
esta asistencia no tiene un fin militar
ni político según la ONU solo
consistiría en el envío de una fuerza de
acción rápida que apoya los servicios de
seguridad de Haití la oficina integrada
de la ONU en ese país Calcula que la
reciente ola de violencia ha desplazado
a 96.000 personas de Puerto Príncipe la
capital haitiana
las pandillas dominan la ciudad bloquean
carreteras controlan el acceso a los
alimentos y la atención médica e impiden
el apoyo humanitario una pesadilla
viviente según Antonio Gutiérrez
secretario general de la ONU quien
visitó el país a inicios de mes y ha
insistido desde hace casi un año en el
refuerzo de la asistencia internacional
el pueblo de ti necesita tomar medidas
para hacer frente a las necesidades
urgentes de seguridad hago un llamado a
los miembros del Consejo de Seguridad y
a todos los países contribuyentes
potenciales relevantes para que actúen
ahora y creen las condiciones para el
despliegue de una fuerza multinacional
que ayude a la Policía Nacional de Haití
una iniciativa que respalda Estados
Unidos desde Guyana el secretario de
estado Anthony blinken pidió acciones
concretas para ayudar a recuperar el
control en Haití